I want to talk about the bazaar
appointment of former Republican
presidential candidate dr. ben Carson to
Donald Trump's cabinet as Secretary of
Housing and Urban Development despite
having previously likened Ben Carson to
a child molester that is weird to say
hey someone's like a child molester hire
them to serve on my cabinet I'll remind
you of the clip remember this he said
he's pathological somebody said he had
faith illogical disease other other
people said he said in the book and I
haven't seen it I know it's in the book
right that he's got a pathological
temper or temperament that's a big
problem because you don't cure that
that's like you know I could say they'd
say you don't
as an example child molester you don't
cure these people you don't cure a child
molester there's no cure for it not only
did Donald Trump like in Ben Carson to a
child molester Carson also has no
experience in the field of urban
development and housing he's a
neurosurgeon who did inspirational
speaking so I started looking at this
path and I was trying to think what
could there be here that explains
appointing ben Carson a Secretary of
Housing and Urban Development and I
thought well Trump seems to think that
the word urban relates directly to black
people and interchangeably during the
presidential debates and the campaign
whenever Trump was asked about
minorities he would talk about inner
cities he would talk about inner cities
clearly interchangeably with black
people and non-white people he kept
talking about urban also maybe because
Ben Carson is black and Trump sees that
the title Secretary of Housing and Urban
Development has the word urban in it he
said Oh urban let me get the black guy I
mean I know it's crazy but I can't
understand why else ben Carson would be
in this position yeah there are a few
other conclusions you can draw to it
because Ben Carson's background is in
neurosurgery and Alex piquing and even
though he grew up in Detroit and was the
benefit of some of these programs that
he's now gonna be in charge of that's
earth and this life experience alone
isn't enough it's very bizarre it's very
bizarre and I'll remind you that his
spokesperson or business manager
or whatever he is Armstrong Williams
actually said and we talked about this
one when it broke quote dr. Carson feels
he has no government experience he's
never run a federal agency the last
thing he would want to do was to take a
position that would [ __ ] the
presidency and you're going to put him
in charge of Housing and Urban
Development and this is a position that
really does do important stuff
number one the secretary of HUD
administers the FHA's mortgage insurance
programs what on earth does dr. ben
Carson know about mortgage insurance
programs the secretary of HUD takes
steps to encourage a strong private
sector housing industry which can also
produce affordable housing which is
probably something ben Carson is against
because he's against so many of these
government subsidies what on earth does
Ben Carson know about the private sector
housing industry the secretary of HUD
employs more than 10,000 workers and the
secretary is the leader of that entire
agency what on earth does ben Carson
know about managing 10,000 workers this
is completely backwards bizarro land
luckily I mean if you look at the
presidential succession line the
Secretary of Housing and Urban
Development is far later it's like 12th
or something yeah yes there's no chance
he's actually gonna become president so
I like what you're doing Pat in looking
for a silver lining here the good news
is that 11 to 14 people I think the the
secretary of HUD is 12th 11 people would
have to simultaneously be killed before
Ben Carson would become President of the
United States that's the silver lining
that you found and I think the agency is
only in charge of about 10,000 people
which compared to other ones isn't as
bad okay well listen you're doing a much
better job than I am of finding these
incredibly obscure silver linings in the
appointment of someone like Ben Carson
to secretary of HUD so there you have it
sleepy hypnotherapist Ben Carson will be
the secretary of HUD
those are confirmation hearings I'm
actually looking forward to because it's
possible that maybe Ben Carson could
learn something about this job before
those hearings send me your thoughts on
this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on twitter at david pakman show and
make sure you're following both Warby
Parker is offering a free five day home
Tryon to give you
the opportunity to check out their
glasses I personally wear Warby Parker
glasses when I'm not wearing my contact
lenses and I also started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trialed comm slash TDPS
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like $300 for prescription glasses high
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing